Stefan, die Verfakten, Spaß und mehr, und überhaupt spielt niemand so gut scharf wie er. Florentin hat immer ein Gag parat, man nennt sie auch das Podcast-Patriarchat. Die beiden Seilen, groß und klein, reissen alle Mauern ein, sind mindestens so legendär wie Robbins und Clouseau.
Und was machst du so? Ich? Ich hör auf! Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO. Ja, wie heißen das Podcast UFO? Wie heißen wir jetzt alle? Du's Foto, Du's Foto, Du's Foto. Herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid bei dieser fantastischen Ausgabe des Podcast-Ufos mit Florentin W. und Stefan Tietze.
Das sind wir, das ikonischste Duo seit?
Ja, seit Robinson Crusoe anscheinend. Lange kam nichts mehr tatsächlich.
Seit Robinson und Crusoe.
Wir sind heute eigentlich zu dritt, denn Leon hat uns eingesungen, hat uns den Herold gemacht, der uns einklingt, die Fanfare in die Fanfare stösst, bevor wir den Raum betreten. Hier ist Stefan der Pfähler. Und Florentin der Geächtete. Sorry, der Geächtete? Ich dachte der Wohltätige. Der Pfähler. Moment mal, woher kommen die... Also erstmal hi, danke, danke, danke. Vielen Dank, aber ganz kurz, kurz, Fehler? Naja, du hast, fails doch schon ganz gerne. Also sorry.
Ist das was Sexuelles? Nein. Dann ja.
Also Sie können das interpretieren, wie Sie wollen.
Okay. In Latein ist das eh alles so wichtig. Ich bin dann zufrieden mit meinem Namen. Gut.
Und ich, was soll ich nochmal? Der Geächtete.
Wer ächtet mich denn?
Sagen wir mal drei, nee, sagen wir mal vier,
sagen wir mal fünf Leute, die mich ächten.
Papst Paulus. Gut, noch einen. Papst, na gut, okay. Papst zählen nicht. Papst zählen nicht. König Henry. Ja, okay, einen noch. Und Francesca di Papadopoli. Ja, okay, gut. Du weisst genau warum. Da wurde mir jetzt wirklich mal der Spiegel vorgehalten. Das ist, ähm gab's Spiegel? Dieses ganze Spiegelspiegel an der Wand Ding?
Ja, das ist auch immer so die alte Sache. In der Frühzeit haben sich die Leute im Wasser gespiegelt, die mussten jeden Morgen raus und mussten erstmal... Und hoffen, dass keine Wellen sind. Bitte keine Wellen, bitte keine Wellen. Und dann sahen wir alle scheisse aus und alle, ja, Wellentag, windiger Tag. Der Kajal so in Wellenformen und denkst dir, ach, ich sehe heute wieder aus, also wirklich, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Aber ja, es war eine harte Zeit damals, vielleicht auch besser, wenn man sich selber gar nicht sehen kann, als wenn man die ganze Zeit mit seinem eigenen Bild konfrontiert ist. Ja, da zeigst du auf mich. Ja, ich zeig auf dich. Wieso, weil ich, weil ich du bin, weil ich dich mit deinem Bild konfrontiere. In gewisser Weise schon, ja, du hast komplett verspiegelte Brillengläser an, ich seh mich die ganze Zeit selbst, als würde ich mit mir selber reden, als würde ich über meine eigenen Witze lachen. Das ist das Nervigste. Manche Menschen haben im Sommer Sonnenbrillen an, wo man sich selber die ganze Zeit sieht. Das ist das Schlimmste, so wie man seine Stimme zu hören die ganze Zeit, so leicht verzögert. Wenn ich dich anschaue, will ich doch dich sehen, nicht mich selbst. Wenn ich dich anschaue, will ich einen anderen Menschen sehen. Ich will auch nicht mich sehen, aber ich will auch nicht dich sehen.
Aber besser als wenn sie für dich selber verspiegelt werden,
dass du immer deine Augen, selber deine Augen siehst,
dass du so switchen kannst
und dann immer deine Augen selber siehst. Das wäre, glaube ich,
auch sehr unangenehm, wenn jemand so ganz nah
an der, hast du manchmal Probleme, Leuten
in die Augen zu gucken? Ja.
Weil ich weiss, linkes Auge, rechte Auge, Mitte.
Ich wechsle immer so ein bisschen, aber man hat das ja eher
ein linkes Auge. Ich versuche es erstmal beim linken Auge. Es ist nicht auch so, wenn man ins linke Auge schaut, lügt man, wenn man ins rechte Auge schaut, weiss man die Wahrheit nicht. Die einzigen zwei Modi, in denen Menschen sprechen können. Ich glaube, wenn man nach oben links guckt, lügt man. Oder war es oben rechts? Als du es gesagt hast, hast du nach oben links geguckt, also hast du gelogen. Um es dir zu veranschaulichen, oder? Weil ich dir bewusst die Unwahrheit erzählen wollte. Ne gut, währenddessen wischst du auch deine schwitzigen Hände an deiner Jeans ab. Also ich glaube, du strahlst. Ich glaube, das Problem ist, es gibt viele Leute, die strahlen ganz viel Lügenenergie aus, ohne dass sie lügen. Ich war gestern beim Arzt. Wirklich, sie waren beim Arzt? Ja, ich hatte einen ganz dringenden Arzttermin. Haben Sie einen, okay, dann zeigen Sie mir mal Ihren Attest. Ähm, ja, das ist klar. Ja, wühlen Sie rum. Sie können direkt sagen, dass Sie nicht beim Arzt waren. Nein, ich glaube, ich habe Finz gerade nicht, ich habe hier so viele andere Sachen. Und dann gibt er den perfekten, ja, okay, Sie waren wirklich beim Arzt. Ja, habe ich doch gesagt. Sie sagen das, als würden Sie lügen. Warum sagen Sie Dinge nicht, wie Sie... Wenn Sie im Arzt waren, warum sollen Sie das selbst... Warum gucken Sie da oben rechts? Ist der gefälscht? Nein, das ist übrigens eine Einsendung, ein kleines Brief. Ein wirklichen Brief. Eine kleine Requisite. Wir haben nämlich Post bekommen. Vielen Dank an alle, die uns immer digitale Post schicken, aber wir alle wissen, digitale Post ist für die Leute, die man nicht so ganz gern mag und Leute, die man richtig gerne hat, denen schickt man einen parfümierten Briefumschlag und den haben wir bekommen, nämlich endlich melden sich die Autoren. Es hat eine Weile gedauert. Wir haben einen Aufruf gestartet zum Thema Autoren und jemand hat einen der Romane geschrieben, die wir in unserer grossen Literaturkritikfolge vorgestellt haben. Das ist das Manuskript? Und jemand hat einen kompletten Roman geschrieben und ihn uns geschickt, so wie es sich gehört, auf Papier, in einem Briefumschlag, uns gesandt, mit einem Reiterboten, ist er einmal durch die Tundra, durch Regen und Sturm geritten, um uns diesen Roman hier vor die Füße zu legen. Ich finde Handschrift immer süss. Ja, toll, ne? Handschrift hat immer was, ist auch fast vergessen. Ich kann auch, glaube ich, nicht mehr Handschreiben. Nee, ich glaube, wenn man dann sagt, schreibt was mit der Hand, ich würde schreiben ihn Vierjähriger. Einfach alles ist krude und kringel überall. Und ich mache manchmal Fehler, dumme Fehler, weil selbst ich vergesse so ein C oder sowas beim SCH. So Dinge, die man eigentlich, die Fehler, die keinen Sinn ergeben, die man nicht machen würde normalerweise, die glaube ich so ein bisschen auch von Tastaturschreiben kommen. Da vergisst man mal ein CH, wenn man sich vertippt oder so was, oder da kommt man ein X rein. Aber ganz komische Fehler machen wir mittlerweile. Toller Brief, also, ich lese vor. Hallo Florentin und Stefan. Hier eine erste, ich kann noch nicht mehr lesen, ist mir auch aufgefallen, wann liest man laut vor nochmal? Ja, das stimmt, ja. Ja. Aber als Streamer sehr oft. Vielen Dank für den Sub von gelmy446-Schinkenstecker. Und dann merkt man, das ist irgendwas obszönes. Und dann denkt man Schinkenstecker, heißt das irgendwas ... Und dann denkt man auch die ganze Zeit so schmutzig, weil man jedes Wort versucht, irgendwie obszön zu machen. Hier ist Harry der Spatz, Spatz, Spitz, Spatz, Spatz, die ganze Zeit. Man hat so einen filthy Kopf die ganze Zeit, wenn man an so schmutzige Sachen denkt. Auch hier wieder Lumen, the medium is the message, denn unter Twitch-Chat ist wirklich nicht die richtige Message. Ganz anders als Papier. Hallo Florentin und Stefan! Hier eine erste Ausgabe des Spiegel-Bestsellers Der Büffel von Helmut Petermann.
Bei grosser Nachfrage würde sich der Ghostreister zu erkennen geben. Einen Wechsel zum Worst Bird Verlag würde ich nicht ausschliessen. Mir gefällt sehr gut dieser kleine Pfeil unten am Zettel, der andeutet, dass es auf der Rückseite weitergeht. Ah, ein Rotationsbrief.
Ein Rotationspfeil. Also, wir haben das komplette Manuskript von Der Büffel von Helmut Petermann gelesen von Stefan Tiberius Titzel. Verlesen? Im Sinne von Vorlesen, nicht im Sinne von Ich verlese mich. Der Büffel, die ungekürzte Originalfassung von Helmut Petermann. Wahnsinn! Der Büffel versetzt Rüffel. Vielen Dank. Das war der Büffel von Helmut Petermann. Er hat sein Werk vorgelegt. Die Öffentlichkeit hat laut geschrien und hier ist es, das Werk ist da, es ist jetzt im Handel erhältlich. Im Worst Bird Verlag könnt ihr es bestellen, 24,99 im Worst Bird Verlag erschienen. Vielen Dank. Aber ein paar Fehler direkt natürlich vom Ghostwriter, erstmal seinen eigenen Namen genannt, den wir wahrscheinlich rausschneiden werden, mit so einem Geistergeklirre, mit so einem Uuuuh überlegen werden. Wahrscheinlich einfach nicht. Exakt das gleiche Geistergeräusch genommen war. Ja, exakt. Es gibt nur ein Geistergeräusch. Kann man das mal in Noten? Das finde ich so in Noten. Das gab es wahrscheinlich auch schon seit Jahrtausenden. Das ist genauso wie das gibt es wahrscheinlich schon seit der Antike. Immer auch immer dieses schöne F. Habe ich aber schon lange nicht mehr gehört. Das macht man nicht mehr, ne? Das stirbt aus.
Berechtigterweise. Man macht es, glaube ich, nicht mehr so im Sinne von Frauen hinterher pfeifen, sondern wenn du halt eine schöne Quarkschnitte siehst.
Also ich meine, das Gebäck, so eine schöne Haselnussquarkschnitte, also wenn du so eine richtig süße Quarkbällchen siehst, im Sinne von Gebäck, dann glaube ich kann man manchmal jauchzend auch pfeifen. Uh, die sehen aber lecker aus. Uh, uh. Ja, es ist immer das Gleiche, ne? Wie würdest du das Uh, uh sagen? Uh, uh. Die kommt ein bisschen aus dem Tierreich, das ist so ein Brunftding, glaube ich. Das war sehr, sehr merkwürdig. Also ich will nicht, dass wenn wir zusammen essen gehen und die Pizzen werden serviert und du dann uh uh. Wie bitte? Nee, das ist eine schöne Pizza, oder? Ja, lecker. Ich will die Vorstellung, dass wir zusammen Pizza essen gehen, finde ich aber auch eigentlich schön. Bist du ein Messer- und Gabel-Esser oder ein schöner Slicer? Nee, bei der Pizza bin ich tatsächlich, mache ich Slices, schön achteln, also erstmal vierteln, dann achteln, dann wird das nie wieder angefasst, das Besteck, für den Rest des Abends. Ach so, ich dachte, die Pizza wird nicht mehr angefangen. Du achtelst es nur und dann isst du einen kleinen Salat. Dann isst du den Salat und die Pizza durch. Aber du magst es einfach mit diesem Roller so drüber zu rollen. Oh, ich habe keinen Roller privat. Ich habe privat das schickere, aber weniger praktische Beil. So ein Hackebeil, so mit zwei Griffen. Wurde mir geschenkt. So ein Pendelbeil, es sieht ein bisschen mittelalterlich aus, ein bisschen wie das, was auf Leute fällt, um sie zu köpfen. Wie dieses Slice-Gillotine-Slicer. Ja, ich habe ja ein Schwert und denke mir auch manchmal, soll ich nicht mein Schwert häufiger in der Küche einsetzen, weil du kannst ja wirklich mit so einer Pizza einmal halbieren mit einem gekonnten Schwerthieb, mit einem behänden Schwerthieb. Jetzt hat mich deine Wortwahl ein bisschen verunsichert. Sollte ich mein Schwert nicht mehr häufiger in der Küche einsetzen? Ja. Durch diese Betonung lässt es mich aber annehmen, dass es woanders häufiger benutzt. Ich sag mal so. Du hast ja gesagt, ich sollte mein Schwert häufiger in der Küche einsetzen.
Dann macht es Sinn, dann benutzt es sonst nicht,
wenn du sagst, ich sollte mein Schwert häufiger
in der Küche einsetzen.
Du hast mich überführt.
Detective Tietze
hat ermittelt.
Ich sag mal so, ich will natürlich auch
in Form sein, weil ich will,
also man
denkt natürlich ab und zu da, was macht man, wenn jemand einbricht, was macht man, wenn plötzlich ein Rüpel in der Wohnung steht. Und warum rüppelt? Ich glaube, wir sind Leute, die eher sich in Heldenfantasien verlieren und denken, ich halte den auf, ich schlage den mit einem gekonnten Hieb den Kopf ab und rufe dann die Polizei an und versuche mich zu erklären. Und das ist so ein bisschen, darüber denke ich nach. Und ich will nicht der Typ sein, der, wenn dann der Rüppel im Hause ist, zu seinem Schwert greift und es dann nicht damit umgehen kann. Das will ich nicht. Ich will dann nicht in der Situation versagen und dann ausgelacht werden, sondern ich will dann schon in den einen oder anderen Hieb landen können. Gehört natürlich auch dazu, dass ich ab und zu mit meinem Schwert dann üben muss, was sich wiederum in meiner Deckenlampe spiegelt, die mittlerweile durchaus geschunden wurde. Die hat einiges gesehen. Was ist das für eine Deckenlampe? Es ist eine Deckenlampe, es ist eine winzige Lampe, winzig, klein. Ganz klein. Also so klein, du würdest es kaum sehen, würde sie nicht leuchten, würdest du sie nicht wahrnehmen. Das ist bei den meisten Lampen so. So winzig. Aber dann, um diesen winzigen Leuchtkörper, ist ein riesiger Papierkugelapparat gebaut. Aber das ist perfekt zum Üben. Mit Draht und riesiger Papierapparat, aber der Leuchtstoff selbst ist also verschwindet. Ja. Also kleiner als ein Glühwürmchen, da ist fast nichts drin, aber ein riesiger Papierkugelapparat drumherum und der kriegt hin und wieder mal einen Stich ab. Und da sind jetzt so ordentlich so Risse, wie man das kennt, so Klischee-Risse, wie man das kennt vom Jurassic Park Logo. Genau, so ein bisschen und oder wenn man eine Katze hat, dann sieht es so aus, als wenn man eine Katze hätte und die gut sehr hoch springen kann. Sehr hoch springen kann, wenn du kleine Lichter hast. Wenn du eine extrem hohe Decken, also 16 Meter hohe Decken und ist unbequem, ist unangemessen und unpraktisch, aber ich genieße es. Und das heißt, du läufst dann mit deinem Schwert durch deine Wohnung und ab und zu trifft es halt mal was. Naja, die ein oder andere Fechtübung findet dann statt und dann entgleitet einem das Todeswerkzeug auch mal. Ich würde dir so gerne mal zugucken am Leben. Ich würde dir so gerne mal einfach eine Woche lang zugucken.
Ich kann mir das entweder sehr gut oder gar nicht vorstellen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Und ich habe Angst, dass ich es mir sehr gut vorstellen kann. Das würde ich ja dann auch nicht machen, wenn jemand da ist. Deswegen glaube ich, bin ich auch lieber alleine, weil immer wenn jemand da ist, denke ich mir, ja, ich würde jetzt lieber Sachen machen, die ich nicht machen würde, wenn jemand da ist. da ist. Ja, ich bin sehr gerne alleine. Ich dachte heute, ich habe heute morgen, ich bin ja gerade in Hamburg hier, weil ich für
Just for the Four Schach kommentiere, andere Geschichte, und dann saß ich im Hotel beim Frühstück und draußen war so ein Eichhörnchen und es war ganz alleine. Und ich habe die ganze Zeit dieses Eichhörnchen beobachtet und es hat dann so, alleine ist es dann so im Garten rumgelaufen, hat so Nüsschen gegessen und sowas und ich dachte mir, ja, ich bin genauso gerne alleine, wie dieses Eichhörnchen gerade alleine ist. Na gut, du weißt aber nicht, ob es gerne alleine ist. Gleich geht es auch wieder zurück in seine Höhle und schaut aus dem Fenster und hat dann die ganze Nüsse da rein. Denkt sich, ich habe so viele Nüsse gesammelt, die kann ich alleine doch gar nicht essen. Du meinst, weil er hat es gegenüber auch so einen Teller hingestellt, mit so einer Nuss drauf. Und in der Mitte ist so eine Kerze, wenn das Eichwännchen guckt, traurig. Und ich sage, oh, ich bin auch genauso gerne alleine. Und es schaut so rüber auf den anderen Baum, wo auch ein anderes Eichwännchen sitzt. Und dann mal so ganz verlegen die Pfote? Keine Ahnung. Du beschreibst gerade so einen Disney-Pixar-Endfilm. Ja, so einen Kurzfilm, so einen extrem kurzen Film, so 16 Sekunden-Filames. 16 Frames. Ist das unsere Kurzfilm-Challenge? Die PDAFGKFZ, die Podcast-UFO-Kurzfilm-Challenge? Die PDAFGFZ, das ist die Podcast-UFO-Kurzfilm-Challenge, wo wir primär GIFs, und zwar machen wir ein GIF-Festival, das erste GIF-Festival. Das erste GIF-Festival, grosse Emotionen. Kurz GIFs. Und es gibt folgende Kategorien. Erotik. Beste Erotik, beste Cinematographie, Gag, lustigste, bestes komödiantisches GIF und Katze, beste Katze. Und beste Katzen, beste Katze und vielleicht beste Schauspieler. Der Untertitel von dem großen Podcast UFO-Kurzfilmfestival lautet Grosse Emotionen, 50 Frames. Die grössten Emotionen in 50 Frames. Und es werden nur Einsendungen angenommen, die genau 50 Frames haben und da muss eine Geschichte erzählt werden. Ja, auch ein Frame drüber, es kann das Böste-Meisterwerk sein, das wird sofort weg vernichtet. Dann kommt der Projektionist und sagt, nein, das kann ich nicht abspielen, das hat mehr als 50 Frames, das kann ich so nicht abspielen. Helmut, ich weiss, du hast andere Probleme zu Hause, aber das musst du ja nicht jetzt hier in deinem... Nein, ich kann das so nicht abspielen. Ich habe nur 50 Frames bei mir im Projektort Platz, das passt uns gar nicht rein, selbst wenn ich wollte, könnte ich es nicht tun. Die Situation ist gerade für uns alle ziemlich schwierig. Reinhard, ich sage es dir doch, ich habe nur 50 Frames Platz, selbst wenn ich wollte, ich könnte es nicht projizieren. Genauso stelle ich mir aber Leute hinter den Kulissen von Filmfestivals vor. Ja, die alle so sprechen wie Schauspieler in deutschen Filmen. Selbst wenn ich wollte, Reinhard, auch oft von einem Nachnamen. Ich kann es einfach nicht tun.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich damit umgehen soll.
Sie sprechen
so, wie Leute Filme
synchronisieren. Aber nicht irgendwelche
Filme, sondern Disney
oder so Kinder, animierte
Kinderfilme. Ja, das ist das Problem. Die Leute
hängen in ihrer Bubble ab und denken, echte Leute
sprechen so. Aber nein, nur Projektionisten
sprechen so. Und danach richtet sich die gesamte Synchro- und deutschsprachige Filmbranche. Schwierig, aber ja, 50 Frames, wir wollen heiße Gifs von euch, 50 Frames und dann schaffen wir es vielleicht, das erste Kurzfilmfestival unter 10 Minuten zu starten. Wie super. Wo ihr kommt, holt euch eine Lachshälfte, einen Shrimp mit Dip und ohne das Festival ist vorbei, noch bevor ihr diese Lachshälfte aufgegessen habt. Noch bevor ihr eure Finger heimlich an eurem Wrack abgeschmiert habt, weil ihr Shrimpsaft dran habt, ist es schon wieder vorbei und ihr könnt nach Hause gehen. Noch bevor der Gedanke, und dafür bin ich jetzt zwei Stunden nach Köln gekommen, auftauchen kann. So, und damit ist das Festival beendet. Ihr könnt nach Hause fahren, macht's gut, schönen Abend. Danke, Jan-Josef Liefers. Der Chauffeur lässt den Motor laufen. Ja, der bringt euch das Untertitel. Der zweite Untertitel. Der Untertitel, der Chauffeur lässt den Motor laufen. Ihr werdet rangefahren an die spanische Riviera natürlich irgendwie, ihr kriegt schon im Auto, kriegt ihr schon Shrimp, keine Sorge. Einen Shrimp. Nicht mehr, aber einen grossen, der so Telefonhörer gross ist. Und vielleicht macht der Chauffeur auch so ein, Herr Tietze, hier ist ein wichtiger Anruf für Sie und hält sich dann den grossen Shrimp so ans Ohr und reicht dir den Shrimp wie ein Telefonhörer. Okay, cool. Und dann nimmst du den und sagst, oh, da kümmere ich mich mal kurz drum. Und dann isst du ihn und dann geht die Tür auch schon auf, du bist noch nicht ganz fertig. Aber er sagt, ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig. Ich lasse den Motor mal laufen. Dankeschön, auch mal dieses Atmen dabei. Dankeschön, wir sind gleich wieder da. Wache nicht auf uns. Ja, Emotionen durch Atmen. Wenn man da mal so ein bisschen drauf achtet, wie viele Emotionen durch Atmen übermittelt werden,
auch bei grossen Schauspielern, manchmal sogar gruselig.
Sätze, die man nur aus Filmen kennt.
Platz 25.
Warte nicht auf mich.
Platz 24.
Ich bin dran.
Ich glaube, wir werden uns nie wieder wiedersehen.
Nie wieder wiedersehen? Ja, okay. Platz 23, ich glaube, wir kriegen Gesellschaft. Oh, schön. Platz 22, ich glaube, das geht nicht gut aus. Ja, Platz 21, ich habe ein ganz mieses Gefühl bei der Sache. Platz 20. Nein! Platz 20. Aber zu welchem Preis? Platz 19. Ja! Ich habe die einfachen Posten bekommen. 18, sehr verbannt. Ja, ich will. Oh, schön. Sehr gut. Es war eine klassische 25 bis 18 Liste. Was ist denn jetzt los? Oh mein Gott. Oh, Stefan. Busy, busy, Stefan. Busy, busy, Stefan. Wir können ja mal direkt auf deinen neuen Karriereweg eingehen, die du eingeschlagen hast. Ich weiß noch, als wir vor sieben Folgen, als du gesagt hast, ich spiele jetzt ein bisschen Schach, da haben wir alle gedacht, naja, ist das nicht wieder eine seiner Phasen? Ist das nicht wieder was, wo wir in zwei Wochen das nächste Hobby hören? Aber nein! Ich topfe jetzt um, ich mache jetzt Kräuter hoch, nächster Hobby, aber nein, es ist tatsächlich aus Stefans Phase eine Karriere entstanden. Er arbeitet jetzt hauptberuflich als Schachkommentator bei Chess24 mit Jan Gustafsson und ist in der Schachszene angekommen und akzeptiert. Nee, angekommen, ja, akzeptiert, nein. Ich bin mit dem grossartigen Jan Gustafsson gerade dabei, das Kandidatenturnier 2020, 2021 zu kommentieren.
Das Turnier, was machen wir uns nichts vor, wirklich, und da betreibe ich es nicht, in gewohrter Stefan Manier, das wichtigste Schachturnier im Schachkalender ist, im sehr kleinen Schachkalender ist. Taschenkalender. Denn da wird der Herausforderer des Weltmeisters Magnus Carlsen gewählt und ermittelt, wer sich da durchsetzt in diesem Turnier. Und das Krass an diesem Turnier ist, das habe ich auch ein bisschen unterschätzt, es ist nicht wie die ganzen Turniere davor, die wir jetzt im Jahr gesehen haben, online mit irgendwie gefühlt zehn Sekunden Bedenkzeit, wo alles schnell geht, viel los, viel Action, wenn noch mal Fehler gemacht, nein, es ist die klassische Bedenkzeit. Heißt, so eine Partie dauert dann gut und gerne mal sechs Stunden. Ja, und ihr müsst kommentieren.
Wir kommentieren dann daneben.
Und dann habe ich auch verstanden, warum Jan Gustafsson mich gefragt hat
und nicht irgendwie einen anderen Schachkommentator,
weil es dann irgendwann an dem Punkt ankommt,
wo man noch drei Stunden ein offensichtliches Remis kommentieren muss,
wo halt die einzelnen Gegner noch versuchen,
so ein bisschen die Steine herumzuschieben und hoffen, dass noch was zu sehen ist, die Engine aber auch schon sagt, nee, das ist ein klares Remis. Und dann schieben die halt noch drei Stunden die Steine hin und her. Und dann kann man auch nicht mehr über Schach reden. Ihr seid Schachkompetentoren, aber ihr redet effektiv 90 Prozent über etwas anderes als Schach. Genau, jetzt regen sich aber dann die Leute, vor allem im Chess24-Chat, weil wir haben ja drei Chats im Blick und die sind alle anders zu charakterisieren. Oh, okay, das ist natürlich immer schwierig. Es gibt den Twitch-Chat, der ist cool, mega cool, mit dem macht es Spaß. Es gibt den YouTube-Chat, nur Assis. Guckt man auch nicht so gern rein, bin ich ganz ehrlich, ich hoffe, hört niemand zu. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Und es gibt den Chess24-Chat, wo nur die Chess24-Premiummitglieder drin rumschreiben. Oh, das sind natürlich die Hardcore-Chess-Fans. Und da wurde auch die Frage gestellt, wie schlägt Stefan sich so? Und dann kam sehr schlecht. Es kam aber auch sehr gut. Oh, okay. Nur Extreme. Also es sind nur Extreme, aber da merkt man, wenn ich dolle Kritiker habe, dann im Chess24 im Just-Renny-Forture, obviously, weil die wollen, dass wir mehr über Schach reden. Ja, das ist toll, das ist so eine schöne Situation. Ich kenne mich ja nicht so gut mit Schach aus, ich schaue das aber trotzdem an. Ich auch nicht. Weil es fast schon ein Sketch-Setup ist von zwei Leuten, die verzweifelt versuchen, Zeit zu füllen mit, oh hast du da einen Fleck auf deinem Jackett? Ist es noch, ja, ich glaube, das ist noch vom, ist das Senf? Ach ja, ich habe ja heute Mittag, hatte ich ja kurz die Bockwurst mit Brot. Oh, jetzt wird gezogen. Isst du auch ganz gern mal eine Wurst mit Senf? Ach, Eremi, ja, ich esse auch. Aber muss man halt aufpassen, wenn man dann mit Anzug isst, dann nicht, dass der Senf. Es ist wie das längste, schlimmste erste Date aller Zeiten, wo man nicht gehen kann, wo man sich entschieden hat, hey, erstes Date, hast du nicht Lust, eine sechs Stunden lange Gondelfahrt zu machen, eine sechs Stunden lange Seilbahnfahrt und man kommt nicht raus und man findet einfach nach vier Minuten schon kein Gespräch. Okay, das ist dann die sehr harsche Kritik von Lorettyn Will. Ehrlich gesagt, mir macht es sehr viel Spaß. Es macht auch Spaß.
Wir labern viel Quatsch. Es ist ein Podcast
von Leuten, die anscheinend
nebenbei noch Schach zu schauen. Ja, das ist es
nämlich. Es ist im Prinzip so ein
High-Concept-Podcast-Setup.
Im Prinzip ist es ein neues Podcast-Projekt,
nur vor einem anderen Hintergrund.
Nämlich, dass man auch Schach kommendiert.
Ja, nee, finde ich gut. Aber es macht Spaß,
es ist lustig, wir haben viel Spaß. Es ist halt einfach nur ein sehr lustiges Setup. Aber es macht wirklich sehr viel Spaß. Und ich bin gespannt, wie lange ich noch da sein darf, bis mich die Chess 24-Community mit Fackeln und Heugabeln aus dem Gebäude jagt. Aber verrückt, dass da jetzt wirklich was draus geworden ist aus seiner Schachliebe, der der grosse Sieg bei Zugzwang und jetzt bist du quasi da angekommen. Ich warte ja immer noch darauf, dich am Zeitschriftenstand auf dem Cover eines Schachmagazins zu sehen. Das wäre für mich der Höhepunkt. Der Rest, klar, Stream und so ist alles cool, aber ich will dich auf dem Cover eines Schach, ich will dich auf Rösselsprung, ich will dich auf Rochade, ich will dich auf diesen Schachzeitschriften wichtig sehen. Ich möchte jetzt wiederverwarten, aber ich wurde angefragt für ein Interview für eine Schachwebsite. Ah, nein! Nein, nein, nein, nein, ich will Print. Du willst Print? Ich will Print. Das wollte ich nämlich fragen. Ich will Print. Wie sehr hängst du an Print? Ich hänge sehr an Print, denn ich bin ein Kind des Bahnhofs, ich bin oft an Bahnhöfen unterwegs und muss oft Wartezeiten überbrücken. Und da ist natürlich die gute alte Zeitschrift ideal. Du gehst da hin und blätterst mal durch und guckst dir. Und ich gehe immer straight zu den weirdesten Zeitschriften, die es gibt. Also vorbei an Playboy, Spiegel, die Klassiker. Ich gehe sofort hin zu dem siebt erfolgreichsten Waffenmagazin, das es gibt. Ich gehe direkt zu dem hässlichsten Anglerzeitschrift, die es gibt. Ja Ich gehe auch nicht zu, selbst in den Nischen gibt es ja Platzhirsche, irgendwie das Modelleisenbahn oder halt natürlich Route und so von dem Anglermagazin. Ammunition, das will man nicht, man will die Kleinen. Aber ich will selbst in der Nische die schlechten, in der Nische die Nischigen. Ja, und was heißt das, du gehst dann da hin, du gehst dann nur hin, oder nimmst du sie auch in die Hand oder kaufst du sie gar?
Das wird erstmal beäugelt und manchmal auch reingeblättert. Ich bin ganz tief drin in diesem Reitsport, wo die aber dann so einen Wagen ziehen, so eine Art Streitwagenwettrennen, ganz merkwürdig. Du bist woanders, du bist in der geschichtlichen Abteilung. Nee, nee, das ist wirklich, gibt es noch, von Pferden, also ein Pferd und dann hast du so eine Schubkarre da hinten, da sitzt einer drin.
Wie ein Kind. Du bist in einer geschichtlichen Abteilung. Nee, nee, das ist wirklich, gibt es noch. Von Pferden, also ein Pferd und dann hast du so eine Schubkarre da hinten, da sitzt einer drin.
Wer, ein Kind?
Nein, nein, ein erwachsener Mensch.
Was ist deine Sitzpose?
Die Knie so oben.
Die sitzen da halt einfach so in so 90 Grad Winkel mit ausgestreckten Beinen und etwas betrübten Gesichtsausdruck und sitzen da und es ist nicht so aufregend. Die werden halt gezogen und dann gibt es Zeiten. Und da gibt es Magazine, die sind wirklich nur dicht gedruckte Zeiten und in welcher Reihenfolge die ins Ziel gelaufen sind, Seite über Seite über Seite über Seite, dicht gedruckt, einfach reine Information. Name des Pferdes, Name des Reiters, Zeit, welches Turnier, welcher Platz und einfach über Zeit. Ich finde das faszinierend. Ich will ja immer noch die Random rausbringen. Die Random, die zufallsgenerierte Zeitschrift. Aber wir konnten uns nicht einigen, ob jedes Magazin anders ist oder pro Woche dieselbe Ausgabe. Ich würde sagen, pro Woche dieselbe Ausgabe. Ich glaube, das ist nicht eine gute Idee. Aber um das realistisch zu machen, glaube ich, müssen wir auf jeden Fall ein Magazin pro Woche rausgeben. Und da ist dann halt ... Alles ist random generiert, aus dem Internet. Das muss uns ja jemand schreiben einfach, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so schwierig. Aber einfach auf jeder Seite sind random Bilder in random Anordnungen mit random Texten. Aber natürlich muss es irgendwie grob zusammenhängen. Also da muss dann auch stehen, Spiegel bestseller Liste, da müssen da fünf random generierte Sachen stehen. Ja, man kann sich ja Rubriken überlegen und dann halt so das Rezept der Woche. Ist halt die Frage, ob man sich das überlegt oder ob das auch aus dem Zufallsgenerator kommt, ob man einen Rubrikgenerator anschmeißt, weißt du? Okay, es gibt einen Rubrikgenerator, der sagt Fischgericht der Woche und dann wird ein Fischgericht zufällig generiert. Und dann muss man der KI sagen, bitte ein Fischgericht bitte, ich bin hungrig. Da muss man eine Beilagen-Engine anschmeissen und eine Fisch-Engine anschmeissen. Aber ich glaube auch, dass es besser ist, wenn alle Ausgaben gleich sind, weil dann können Leute drüber reden. Hast du die Random diese Woche gelesen? Ja, ich habe die Random diese Woche gelesen. Hast du den Artikel gelesen über die Solarenergie? Ich war verzweifelt. Ich bin ganz immer noch aus dem Häuschen. Dass die Raben und die Solarenergie, dass das überhaupt zusammenpasst, damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet. Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet, dass die Sonne auch darauf einen Einfluss hat. Und so sprechen Leute dann beim Friseur miteinander über die neue Random. Ja. Ist das unser nächster Coup? Ich glaube, die Random ist der nächste Coup. Den am Zeitschriftenstand? Ich fände, also ohne Scheiss, ich würde die wahnsinnig gerne lesen. Ich glaube auch, dass eigentlich jetzt Print eigentlich nur noch mehr für Gags gemacht ist. Also es gibt, jeder Late Night bringt jetzt ihr Gag-Zeitschrift raus. Und wir auch, ich glaube, irgendwann denken sich auch so Printlädenbesitzer, Leute, nimmt das keiner mehr ernst? Ich bin überzeugter Magazinleser und jetzt nur noch hier so Fake-Hipster-Satire-Magazin. Jeder Podcast hat sein eigenes Magazin. Ich bin auch dafür, diese bedeutungsschwangere Unterschrift, random, die Antwort auf unser Zeitgeschehen. Oh. Weil es echt die Antwort ist super. Oder der Untertitel wird natürlich auch zufällig generiert. Natürlich wird er zufällig generiert. Auf Amadeus und Sabrina, zum Beispiel einfach nur. Zum Beispiel. Weil ich finde, es ist schon eine gute Antwort auf unser Zeitgeschehen gerade. Wir umgeben uns nur mit Dingen, wir beeinflussen unsere Wirklichkeit, wir leben in unseren Filter-Bubbles, das piekst die Bubbles auf. Ja, man wird dann nicht mehr von irgendwelchen Algorithmen kontrolliert, sondern man wird vom Zufallsgenerator. Maximale Durchlässigkeit, maximal wenig Einfluss. Komplett ein Kontrollverlust, das ist eine Kontrollverlustzeitschrift. So heißt dann die uncole Zeitschrift der Kategorie. Irgendwann ist nämlich eine Kategorie. Willkür ist dann bei W. P ist Pferde, S ist Streitwagen, Pferde und W ist Willkür. Nein, wenn du beim Zeit, wilde Pferde, Willkür. Das ist, wenn du beim Zeitschriftenhändler stehst, ist wir in der Kategorie Willkür die unbedingte Zeit.
Aber es kann schon sein, dass sich alles mehr zu Nonsens entwickelt. Auch wenn man sich mal den Humor anguckt, so diesen Meme-Humor, wo immer mehr Ironieschichten aufeinander gestapelt werden. Und wenn man dann nicht immer on top des Games bleibt, versteht man schnell gar nichts mehr. Ja, und ich habe jetzt, es gibt es auf, also ich bin ja wieder auf Instagram Reels unterwegs, da gibt es jetzt auch immer so diesen Variantenhumor. Da gibt es immer so diese Situation, jemand geht, also einer sitzt im Auto, der andere kommt an Auto und sagt, hey, danke, dass du da warst, geben sich die Hand und der andere fährt mit dem Auto weg. Und das wird in tausenden Möglichkeiten variiert. Also der sagt dann, tschau, macht's gut und fährt dann rückwärts aber weg. Oder der wirft ihm irgendwie Nudeln ins Gesicht als Verabschiedung und dann fährt er weg. Und das geht, das schraubt sich immer weiter. Es spiralt sich in ungeahnte Höhen. Es wird immer absurder, es wird immer merkwürdiger und irgendwann denkt man sich auch, das ist einfach, am Ende ist einfach Nonsens, einfach wirklich Nonsens. Und da kann ich mir auch denken, so was wie Loriot oder sowas, das hat man angeschaut, selbst du durchschaust Loriot, das versteht jeder. So lustig, man macht sich das Bürgertum lustig, versteht man. Aber wenn du heute mal auf Instagram guckst und so willkürlich in Reels reinschaust, vergiss es, keine Chance. Du brauchst eine Leseranleitung eigentlich. Du brauchst eigentlich so ein Reklam-blaues Büchlein, Instagram Stories. Lektüreschlüssel. Instagram Reels. So einen Lektüreschlüssel bräuchte man eigentlich, um da reinzukommen. Und ich glaube, irgendwann verliert man sich in Nonsens und es ist einfach nur noch Nonsens und dann sind wir zufrieden. Wie ich es auch häufig mache, wenn ich ein Thema nicht verstehe, hole ich mir dann dafür das zugehörige Sachbuch, um mich da reinzulesen. Oh, ich habe mir auch ein Sachbuch. Aber wie geil wäre denn diese pinke Ausgabe über Memes? Ja, das finde ich auch gut. Das finde ich gut, weil ich komme auch nicht so richtig rein. Pippethefrog, da hat mir die Doku geholfen, aber auch nicht richtig. Also woher kommen solche Sachen? Aber auch das Buch ist auch komplett in Memes geschrieben, so in dem Loss-Format, in diesem Vier-Panel-Format, das auch super abstrakt wurde. Ach so meinst du das, ja. Das ist auch abgefahren. Aber ja, verrückt, ich habe mich überhoben die Woche. Das ist nicht verhoben. Ich habe mich verhoben die Woche und... Wie konnte das denn passieren? Ja, ja, ich war auf Amazon unterwegs und ich wollte mir ein Buch holen, ein Sachbuch. Ein Sachbuch? Ein Sachbuch, aber ich habe mich verhoben.
Was für ein Sachbuch ist es denn geworden? Man denkt sich ja immer, Mensch, du bist ein kluges Kerlchen, du hast Abitur, du kannst dich auch mal in Themen reinbeissen. Und auch wenn du es auf Anhieb nicht verstehst, kannst du dich einarbeiten und hier guckst du mal auf Wikipedia und so und das kriegst du schon hin. Und das Buch war schon, ja, und dann dachte ich mir, das passt schon und dann habe ich es von der Packstation abgeholt und es war schon echt auch ein Klopper, es lag schon auch in der Hand, also da hatte wirklich das Wissen. Hast du denn bei der Packstation schon immer, dass du einen Fehler begangen hast? Ich habe bei der Packstation, ich habe schon, als ich den Code in der Packstation eingegeben habe und eine grosse Tür aufgegangen ist. Das ist immer aber geil. Da wusste ich schon. Du fühlst dich auch wie in so einer Gameshow eigentlich. Wenn du da den Code eingibst und dann geht irgendwo, hörst du so ein Plack. Und du guckst dich um und denkst, wow, und dann steht hinter dir so ein Auto mit so einer grossen Schleife und dann hast du es gewonnen. Ich versuche immer zu raten, welche Tür aufgeht und ich lag noch nie richtig. Und mittlerweile denke ich mir, wow, das ist auch eine Leiste, nie richtig zu liegen. Nein, ich habe bestimmt schon hundert Sachen aus der Pappstation abgeholt. Du bist bei der falschen Station. Im letzten Jahre. Ich habe schon ein paar Mal gesagt, geh zur Pappstation, nicht daneben, sondern die Pappstation. Nicht für Kinder. Und ich lag noch nie richtig. Und ich denke mir, wenn du zum Beispiel bei Roulette, wenn du versuchst, das richtige Ergebnis zu schätzen, das ist beeindruckend, wenn du sagst zwölf und es kommt zwölf. Aber es ist auch beeindruckend, wenn du es dein Leben lang kein einziges Mal schaffst. Ja, es ist beeindruckend, das Problem ist, nur du hast dann davon nichts. Richtig, ja. Genau, und so mache ich es auch bei der Parkstation, und dann, wenn du, du merkst schon, okay, du gibst ein, oh, mein Buch ist da, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, klonk, riesige Trissor. Trolle, Trolle ziehen diese riesige Tür auf. Ja, Steintür, Granitür. Diese riesige Tür, wo du gar nicht gesehen hast, dass es überhaupt eine Tür ist, wird von zwei grossen Trollen, und dahinter ist so ein Ork mit so einem Peitschen. Hier, Meister, eine riesige Truhe wird rausgeschoben. Eine Truhe wird rausgetragen, die man selber nicht kommt. Dann kommt Gandalf an und sagt, Melon. Und dann die Truhe auch nochmal. Und dann geht dann auf. Und dann liegt da drin das, was du bestellt hast. Da ist mein Sachbuch drin, und ich merke schon, oh, habe ich mich vielleicht verhoben. Und ich habe mir bestellt die Physikformelsammlung für Ingenieure und Naturwissenschaftler. Die Physik-Formelsammlung für Ingenieure und Naturwissenschaftler. Und ich dachte mir schon, bin ich Ingenieur? Der Herr Ingenieur! Ich bin weder Ingenieur noch Naturwissenschaftler und ja, ich habe mich absolut verhoben. Ich dachte, eine Formelsammlung in der Schule, dachte man so, wait a second, du hast aber, der Fehler ist ja vorher passiert. Der ist ja nicht, wir haben es gerade auf die Pappstation bezogen, aber der Fehler ist ja schon bei Amazon passiert. Der ist schon bei Amazon passiert, aber ich dachte mir, ich kann mich da einlesen, weil das ist ein Ingenieur anders als ein Mensch, der halt ein paar Wikipedia-Artikel gelesen hat. So, das kriege ich schon auch hin. Und ich dachte mir so, weil ich habe ja aus der Schule so Formelsammlungen, halt so Geschwindigkeit ist Weg durch Zeit. Ja, verstehe ich. Habe ich jetzt schon verstanden. Das geht, das kann ich handhaben. Und ich schlage dieses Buch auf und forget it, vergiss es. Also wirklich auch Beispiele, Erklärungen, dann irgendwie in verschiedenen Feldern. Hier nochmal anschaulich. Genau, hier nochmal anschaulich. Wenn B gleich Y durch C² ist, ist C gleich F. Immer dieses Integralzeichen. Ich dachte mir dann so, Sachen, die ich verstehe. Freier Fall, easy. Freier Fall, versteht man. Irgendwas wird immer schneller und irgendwann nicht mehr, weil der Luftwiderstand dann die gleiche Kraft auswirkt wie die Beschwerdung, die Schwerkraft, easy. Schau ich unter F, FF, freier Fall und ein riesiges Integralzeichen und Summe und Wurzel und 13 Konstanten und 5 Bilder und so dieser süße Bär mit dem Daumen nach oben. Nein, hau ab so, das ist du, du bist so krass. War das noch ein Buch mit süßen Bären und lustigen Zeichnungen?
Es war ein Buch, das dir vermittelt hat, du kannst es verstehen, aber du kannst es nicht verstehen.
Können Ingenieure das verstehen?
Ich glaube auch nicht, ich glaube Ingenieure verstehen das auch nicht.
Aber ich muss, ich will noch nicht spoilern, das wird vielleicht noch zu sehen sein, aber ich musste was bauen, etwas physikalisch anspruchsvolles, sagen wir mal.
Und ich möchte es noch nicht spoilern, aber dafür...
Oh mein Gott, dafür hast du es geholt.
Ja, dafür musste ich, ich wollte ein bisschen Grundlagenforschung betreiben, wie das alles funktioniert mit den Kräften.
Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin bei Physik immer sofort raus. Ich bin bei Physik immer sofort raus. Und ich weiß, ich kann dir... Also manche Sachen versteht man ja einfach nicht. Aber ich kann dir bei Physik den genauen Moment sagen, wo ich bei Physik raus war. Das Integralzeichen? Nee, es war in der Schule, als mein Physiklehrer gesagt hat, so, jetzt geht's los mit Kräften. Ich dachte mir, okay, gut. Warst ready, ne? Ich war bereit, ich hab mich vorgelehnt. Nach der zweiten großen Pause, du warst wohlgelehrt, warst fertig. Ich hab gerade einen Ballisto genascht, schön Bleistift angespitzt, Bleistift war spitz, Papier war leer. Ich sagte, los geht's. Dein Nacken hat nochmal geknackt und dann schön streichst du die Haare aus dem Gesicht und vorne dein Schreibtisch wohl sortiert. Rechts Etui? Genau. Hattest du so ein grosses oder so ein kleines Faulenzer? Ich hatte ein relativ grosses, ich hatte noch das aus der Schule mit Motiven, mit Mäusen, die Käse hinterherlaufen. Dann vor dir so ein Millimeterpapier? Genau, Geodreieck, Periodensystem. Kaputtes Geodreieck. Taschenrechner, ja natürlich, klar. Mehrfach und da so. Dann Radiergummi, wo aber die blaue Seite gefehlt hat schon. Ja, absolut. Alles war da und der Lehrer sagt, so, ich habe jetzt eine Kugel, die lege ich auf den Tisch. So, und jetzt machen wir mal diese... Allein, euer Lehrer ist jetzt schon cool aus unserer... Und jetzt kommen die Pfeile. Die Kugel wirkt ja eine Kraft nach unten aus, weil die von der Schwerkraft angezogen wird. Okay, alles klar. Am Sillen. Ich bin dabei, Pfeil nach unten, alles klar, cool, zeigt zum Erdmittelpunkt, wo die Feen sind, die die Schwerkraft erzeugen. So, Pfeil nach unten und der Tisch wirkt jetzt eine genauso grosse Kraft nach oben aus. Und ich war sorry, der Tisch drückt nach oben und das war der Moment, wo ich raus war. Das war schon der Moment, an dem ich raus war. Ganz kurz, das kriegen wir zusammen hin. Weil ich dachte, warum der Tisch drückt nach oben, warum, und ich verstehe, dass sich momentan nichts bewegt, also müssen die Kräfte im Gleichgewicht sein, okay, aber ich verstehe nicht, warum, und dann hatte der Tisch so einen senkrechten Pfeil nach oben, und ich denke mir, was hat der, warum strebt der Tisch nach oben, wo will der hin, was hat der Power? Warum strebt der Tisch nach oben? Der Tisch strebt gen Sonne. Wo will der hin? Was ist sein Problem? Und dieser Pfeil zeigt nach oben vom Tisch aus und ich war raus. Ich war ab dem Moment, war ich verloren. Moment, das kriegen wir zusammen, kriegen wir es gelöst. Und ich bin wie so eine Figur, die so in so ein schwarzes Loch fällt und sich so langsam dreht und so die, das Klassenzimmer wird immer ferner und ferner und ich höre es noch dumpf, integral und ich falle und ich bin ganz tief unten, ganz tief weg und das war's und diesen Punkt habe ich seitdem
nicht aufgehoben.
Ganz kurz, das kriegen wir zusammen hin, liegt die Kugel mit dem senkrechten Pfeil nach
unten, ja, da sind wir safe.
Liegt die aber auf einem
Stuhl?
Hätte der genauso, würde der genauso
gen Himmel streben.
Ich habe ganz viele Fragen. Erstens, woher weiß der Tisch, dass er
drücken muss? Was passiert, wenn ich
die Kugel schlagartig wegnehme? Springt der
Tisch dann hoch oder nicht? Was passiert
dann? Ich meine, ich kann mir das alles schon so
vorstellen, aber allein die Darstellung,
dass der Tisch jetzt
gerade nach, ich kann es mir vorstellen, wenn
Vielen Dank. Tisch dann hoch oder nicht? Was passiert dann? Ich meine, ich kann mir das alles schon so vorstellen, aber allein die Darstellung, dass der Tisch jetzt gerade nach, ich kann es mir vorstellen, wenn ein Mensch die Kugel hält, der Mensch drückt nach oben und wenn man dem Menschen die Kugel wegnimmt, dann geht die Hand kurz hoch. Naja, dann wird er von seiner Hand 16 Meter in die Luft gerissen, das kennen wir alle aus dem täglichen Leben. Das kennen wir alle. Groses Problem. Und da denke ich mir, okay, verstehe ich. Aber wenn jetzt die Kugel auf dem Boden liegt. Nee, nur ganz kurz. Ja genau, der Boden drückt dagegen. Ist der Boden auch nach oben? Der Boden drückt nach oben, mit allem was er hat. Ist der Boden nicht der Tisch? Ist nicht egal, was... Es ist die Frage, manchmal sind Tische der Boden, manchmal ist der Boden aber kein Tisch. Also das stimmt schon, wenn man die Erde als das versteht, worauf die Kugel gedrückt wird, wegen Anziehungskraft, Gravitation, es ist schon weird, dass es da überhaupt eine Kraft gibt, die nach außen drückt. Ja schon. Weil, aber sonst müsste es ja auf den Erdkern drücken. Ja, sonst würde die Kugel einfach durch den Tisch durchwabern. Das ist ja nicht der Fall. Aber der Tisch ist ja egal, der ist ja austauschbar, auch meinetwegen für den Berg. Du kannst ja die Kugel auch auf den Mount Everest legen. Aber damit lösen wir unser Problem nicht, wenn wir einfach nur die Bezeichnungen ändern. Doch, für mich wird es ein bisschen anschaulicher, ehrlich gesagt. Der Tisch, der gen Himmel strebt, dieser ambitionierte Ja, das ist so. Und jetzt legen wir eine schwere Kugel drauf.
Jetzt drückt der Tisch noch mehr nach oben.
Tisch!
Woher war es der Tisch?
Tisch, komm runter! Woher war es der Tisch?
Wie schwer die Kugel ist, wie hart er drücken muss.
Der Tisch drückt mich.
Und wann geht ihm die Kraft aus? Hat er irgendwann, oh nö.
Weil beim Mensch denke ich mir, klar, der Mensch hält die Kugel und muss Kraft aufwenden und es wird immer schwieriger und irgendwann hält der die Kugel nicht mehr. Beispiel, dein Riesensachbuch, was du jetzt geholt hast, das war zu schwer. Ein Almanach, das legst du jetzt auf diesen Tisch und der Tisch wollte noch nie so sehr in seinem Leben nach oben. Verstehst du? Der ist jetzt sehr ambitioniert.
Ja, genau. Also die Pfeile sind wahnsinnig lang.
Beide und exakt gleich lang.
Problem, der Tisch ist nicht dafür gemacht, für diese Art großer Pfeil.
Ja, bricht zusammen.
Bricht zusammen. Das Buch schnellt mit der Freierfall.
9,81 Meter pro Sekunde ist ja unsere Anziehungskraft hier in Deutschland auf den Boden.
So, jetzt drückt der Boden den Himmel.
Ah ja, und einmal ganz viel und dann wieder weniger, meinst du?
Und der Tisch ist kaputt gegangen unter der Größe, weil er das nicht aushält, weil der das Buch zu sehr gern Boden gestrebt hat. Ja. Ja? Mhm. Jetzt schrebt der Tisch nirgendwo mehr hin. Nee. Außer Richtung Müll. Genau, der hat dann die Müllanziehungskraft. Müll, ein senkrechter Pfeil. Das ist der grüne Pfeil mit so einem Recycling-Symbol. Ja, grüner Pfeil. Der strebt direkt auf den nächsten Mülleimer. Stinkender grüner Pfeil nach rechts. Mit einer Kraft von Wurzelintegral, Abstand zum Müll, Mülltüten dicke, Mülltüten breite. Mal Faulheit zum Hydrat. Genau. Also im Grunde ist es total leicht. Aber ich weiß noch, und ich meine, ich verstehe das schon grob, was damit gemeint ist mit diesem Pfeilen, aber ich weiß noch, dass ich mir damals dachte, diese Physik, diese Realität, diese, ja sagen wir mal, echte Welt, das ist nichts für mich, das ist mir zu, das ist nichts. Bei mir war es ein anderer Moment, und zwar, ich habe alles, also es wurde so gleich, es wurde richtig gut hergeleitet, diese ganze Relativitätstheorie wurde von einem Physiklehrer geil hergeleitet. Ist gleich mc Quadrat. Und es gibt viele andere Formeln, wo bla bla bla ist leicht, bla bla bla zum Quadrat. Und ich denke, das kann doch nicht sein. Wo ist das Quadrat in der ganzen Nummer? Wie kommt man darauf? Wie kommt man auf Quadrat? Ja, das ist genau mal sich selbst. Warum nicht hoch 1,9? Warum nicht jede andere Zahl? Warum genau mal sich selbst? Welches Brain kommt denn darauf? Das hat für mich kein... Ja, das ist ja die grosse... Ja, das ist schwierig. Das ist das Wunderberg der Physik. Ja, ich weiß nicht wo, und das tut auch weh, weil das echt schwer ist. Und das ist schwierig. Hast dulegt, das auf die Strasse zu stellen, mit einem zum Verschenken? Auf gar keinen Fall. Da hätte ein Lastwagen und ein Gabelstapler kommen müssen, um das abzuholen. Das ist so schwer, das Buch. Wo liegt dein Brot gerade, wollte ich fragen? Das liegt momentan auf meinem Tisch. Und dein Tisch, wo ist der? Hängt der schon an der Decke oder ist der? Nee, der wird von dem Buch gerade noch unten gehalten. Gott sei Dank hast du sehr viele Sachen, die du auf deine Gegenstände legen kannst, damit sie nicht wegfliehen. Du musst immer gucken, bevor du die Wohnung verlässt, liegt auf jedem Gegenstand noch ein anderer drauf. Fuck, fuck, nein! Was ist passiert? Ich habe auf dem Stuhl nichts gelegt. Oh, fuck, Stefan! Ich habe auf alle Stühle, ich habe extra noch gedacht, zu Hause, ich habe auf alle Stühle was gelegt, aber auf dem einen ist. Scheiße, nee, die Kraft, die drückt ja nach oben. Wenn da nichts draufliegt, dann haut der ab. Wie muss ich die wieder runterbekommen? Der hängt jetzt an der Decke. Ärgerlich, wenn man nach Hause kommt und alles hängt an der Decke. Und du hast ja so ein wunderschönes Deckenfenster. Das passiert einem einmal und nie wieder. Ja, genau, das Deckenfenster strebt aber runter, ist mir schon aufgefallen. Ja, wenn er so einen Stuhl dran hängt an der Decke. Und du hast ja so ein wunderschönes Deckenfenster. Das passiert einem einmal und nie wieder. Ja genau, das Deckenfenster strebt aber runter, ist mir schon aufgefallen. Ja, wenn da so ein Stuhl dran hängt oben, weil der Stuhl raus will, drückt... Das Deckenfenster strebt nach unten, ja. Ähnlich stark, ich würde fast sagen, identisch stark nach unten wie der Stuhl nach oben. Was auch nach unten strebt, sind unsere Träume. Sie liegen fast ab Boden, sie liegen fast im Dreck. Wie viele Nachrichten hast du bekommen? Wahnsinnig viele Nachrichten. Und da muss man nochmal sagen, da müsst ihr euch auch besser absprechen daraus. Ja, wirklich. Wenn ihr irgendwas in den Medien lest, was denkt, dass uns gefällt, sprecht euch bitte ab, nutzt die Telegram-Gruppe und sagt, hat das schon jemand Stefan geschickt? Und was ich in diesem Fall noch am wichtigsten finde, hört die Folgen nach.
Alte Folgen nach.
Oder schau dir in der Puffopedia nach. Denn es wurde nichts Neues rausgefunden. Du spielst hier an. Auf die Schlagzeile. Unsere neue Rubrik. Das Dino-Podcast. Und wir haben letzte Woche schon darüber gesprochen, dass der T-Rex wahrscheinlich nicht nur unangenehme Haare hatte, Sandalen getragen hat, ein Pailletten, also Sakko anhatte, sondern auch, ja, mollig war, ein bisschen hatte schwere Knochen. Und eher walförmig, blabberförmig. Und jetzt kam noch mal die gnadenlose Nachricht, die die T-Rex-Welt für Laien noch mal erschüttert hat, denn Welt.de titelt mit Tyrannosaurus Rex ging etwas langsamer als ein Mensch. Was für eine Überschrift mässig reißerisch ist, Tyrannosaurus Rex ging etwas langsamer. Unmerklich langsamer. Es würde quasi nicht auffallen, langsamer als ein Mensch. Und hier sind schon mal zwei Dinge drin, die ich herausstellen möchte. Erstmal Menschen gehen sehr langsam. Gehen sehr langsam. Vor allem, warum sprechen wir überhaupt über Gehen? Also wenn ich mir einen T-Rex vorstelle, dann rennt der wirklich mit voller Geschwindigkeit, auf seinen Opfer zu, brüllt. Und hier geht es um Geh, um Spazieren, um Schlendergeschwindigkeit. Bummeln. T-Rex bummelt. T-Rex schlenderte etwas langsamer, als ein Mensch schlenderte. Das heißt, nur weil jemand genauso schnell geht, heißt es ja nicht, dass er die gleiche Höchstgeschwindigkeit hat. Es ist merkwürdig. Und Menschen gehen unterschiedlich schnell. Es gibt Leute, die haben diesen Ruderarm und gehen relativ zügig von A nach B. Dann sind Leute wie dich, die so sehr langsam rumwarbern. Hier, Gehtempo der Giganten auf etwa 1,28 Meter pro Sekunde, also auf die zweite Nachkommastelle kann man mittlerweile schon die Trödelgeschwindigkeit eines T-Rex bestimmen. Zum Vergleich, die durchschnittliche Gehgeschwindigkeit von Menschen beträgt demnach etwa 1,34 bis 1,42 m pro Sekunde. Also, falls ihr euch fragt, gehe ich gerade, dann müsst ihr gucken, bewegt ihr euch zwischen 1,34 und 1,42 m pro Sekunde. Was eine Antwort auf eine andere Frage ist, die wir schon mal gestellt haben.
Genau, alles über 1,42 ist wächsen, ist hecheln. Also da müsst ihr gucken, also ich finde es geil, dass die Gehgeschwindigkeit des Menschen auch wieder auf die zweite Nachkommastelle bei m pro Sekunde definiert ist.
Jetzt hilft mir m pro Sekunde nicht so richtig viel. Naja, man kann, ja, du hast eine Fuchtelbewegung gemacht, aber du hast sehr schnell gefuchtelt. Was ist ein Meter? Mach mal einen Meter. Und jetzt 21,2 und 21,2 und so. Boah, geht mal langsam, ey. 1,4 Sekunden. Aber das ist ja in der T-Rex ging noch langsamer. Ja, T-Rex ist super langsam, aber das wussten wir schon. Ja, das wussten wir nämlich daher, weil in New York war ich ja am Zahn der Zeit, sprichwörtlich am stumpfen T-Rex-Zahn der Zeit, war ich ja im National History Museum in New York. Und da war ich in einer T-Rex-Ausstellung, wo die neuesten Erkenntnisse ausgestellt wurden, wo wir auch herausgefunden haben, dass er lange graue Haare hatte. Und in dieser Ausstellung, da wurde schon gesagt, dass er wahrscheinlich Assfresser war, weil er so langsam nur gehen konnte, weil er war so schwer und so groß, immerhin, dass immer zwei Beine auf dem Boden sein mussten. Aber er hat ja nur zwei. Genau. Also kann er sich gar nicht bewegen. Nee, also wenn wir rennen, dann hebt, dann sind manchmal haben wir eine Luftphase, weißt du, Menschen. Ja, aber wenn du immer zwei Füße am Boden hast, dann kannst du ja gar nicht anfangen zu laufen. Sorry, immer ein Bein auf dem Boden haben. Immer ein Bein, okay. Weil der Rest strebt, weil Erde, die Erde strebt nämlich, so ist er wie der Dino auf dem Boden. Ja, sonst hebt er ab Und das ist nämlich wichtig, dass er immer einmal auf dem Boden ist,
weil sonst bricht die ganze Physik zusammen.
Das wäre ja schlecht.
Das wäre nicht gut und deswegen wussten wir das schon.
Der geht so langsam, dass er auch keine anderen Dinosaurier jagen konnte.
Er hätte nur Aas gegessen.
Ist Gehen denn der einzige Modus für einen T-Rex oder kann der nicht auch mal sich beeilen
oder wirklich mal so, ich komme zu spät, hudeln? Ich glaube, es geht nicht, wegen seiner Größe. Aber jeder, der gehen kann der nicht auch mal sich beeilen oder wirklich mal so ich komme zu spät hudeln?
Ich glaube, es geht nicht, wegen seiner Größe.
Aber jeder, der gehen kann, kann auch rennen.
Ja, aber jetzt kommen wir zum Thema
der letzten Woche, der war ja auch ein bisschen stämmiger.
Er hat ja ein bisschen mehr auf den Rippen.
Weißt du?
Du stell dir mal vor, wie der geht.
Und jetzt müsste er so Ruderarme haben,
aber hat er ja nur ganz kleine Ärmchen.
Ja, aber du kannst doch trotzdem für ein paar, für einen Sprint ansetzen.
Nein, doch nicht, wenn nur 50 Kilo 50 Tonnen liegt.
Welches Tier kann denn nur gehen und nicht rennen?
Aber jetzt stell dir mal so einen riesengroßen, schlechtes Beispiel, Elefanten vor.
Ja.
Ja, deswegen sage ich ja schlechtes Beispiel. Ja, die rennen. Aber die sind auch nicht so schwer wie die T-Rex. Jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie du rennst, also wenn du jetzt wirklich ganz technisch bist und sagst, Rennen ist dann, wenn du eine Luftphase hast, wo kein Fuß mehr den Boden berührt. Okay, aber ich meine jetzt halt wirklich sowas, ich laufe so schnell ich kann. These, und ich glaube, wir brauchen langsam ein paar Leontologen im Podcast, da hätte sie mal ein Buch kaufen können. These, die T-Rex konnte nicht rennen, weil Rennen sagt, ich müsste eine Luftphase haben, in gewisser Weise ist mal weniger als ein Fuß auf dem Boden. Das geht nicht. Dann knallt die Erde auf die Sonne. Ich finde aber auch ehrlich gesagt dreist, was die deutsche Medienlandschaft daraus gemacht hat. Ich habe da Schlagzeilen gelesen wie Trödelt-Rex, dass jetzt da mit so einer Leidenschaft und Freude da auf den T-Rex eingeschlagen wird, der halt ein bisschen langsamer ist, der ist halt ein bisschen ... Wohl eher Trödelsaurus-Rex.
Ja, der lässt sich halt Zeit auch manchmal. Also der ist halt nicht so gehetzt.
Und ich finde, das ist ja eine Qualität, die auch nicht schlecht ist.
Und dass man da jetzt von allen Seiten darauf einschlägt, weil der ehemalige Tyrann jetzt plötzlich eher so ein Ministerpräsidenten-Rex ist und nicht mehr so furchteinflößend ist, weiß ich nicht, ob ich da dahinter stehe und hinter dieser Schmach. Ganz ehrlich, also, nee, da waren wir schon weiter in den Podcast. Wir waren schon weiter. Vielleicht muss er unbenannt werden irgendwann. Vielleicht muss er irgendwann nur noch Rex heißen. Einfach, ich meine, er hat den kurzen Namen. Saurus Rex. Saurus Rex. Ja. S-Rex. Oder Spaziersaurus Rex, sowas in der Richtung. Trödelsaurus finde ich fies. Ne, Trödelsaurus ist ein bisschen, Bummelsaurus, das ist ein bisschen zu viel. Und Bummelsaurus gibt es bestimmt auch schon. Gibt es auch schon. Aber Spaziersaurus Rex finde ich super, weil Spazieren ist eine Qualität in sich. Spazieren ist ein ehrenvolles Lustwandeln, ein ehrenvolles resignatives Schlendern, aber nicht unbedingt lächerlich. Geniesst er Saurus Rex, er läuft ein bisschen durch die Welt, schaut sich mal um, pfiff wunderschöne Melodeien. Und er hat leider, weil wir haben seine Füsse angeguckt, ah, da kommt er wieder. Hallo, Herr Rex! Er nimmt seinen grossen Hut ab. Hallo! Hallo! Lasst mir was übrig zum Futtern. Keine Sorge. Ich brauchuche noch ein bisschen! Keine, wir haben Zeit! Wir haben ja keinen Zeitdruck! Moment mal, wird es denn schon Abend? Warum wird es plötzlich so dunkel? Was verdunkelt denn da die Sonne? Moment mal, eine grosse Wolke? Was ist das vor der Sonne? Es wird plötzlich dunkel. Nein! Es wird plötzlich dunkel. Da scheint irgendwas auf uns zuzurasen. Herr Rex, beeilen Sie sich! Kommen Sie schnell zu uns nach Hause, dann sind Sie sicher. Schnell, Herr Rex, da rast irgendwas auf uns zu! Ich kann doch nicht so schnell! Ein riesiger Meteorit! Ich kann doch nicht so schnell! Gott sei Dank, ich weiß nicht, was er versucht nicht! Schnell, nein, Sie müssen sich beeilen! Schnell, Herr Rex! Ich bin zu lang! Herr Rex, nein! Fällt auf den... Und so ist der T-Rex ausgestorben, aber die Bieber, die ich in dieser kurzen Szene spielen durfte, haben überlebt. In der Rolle des Biebers, wie ich es will. In der Rolle des Spaziersaurus-Rex, Stefan Tietze. Vielen Dank. Dankeschön. Dankeschön. So wird das wahrscheinlich gewesen sein und ja, es ist tragisch. Aber siehst du die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass irgendwann ein anderer Dinosaurier die Spitze, die Nummer eins Spitze nimmt? Ehm, man sucht ja schon krampfhaft danach. Man zweifelt nach einer Tonfolge, aber stellen Sie heraus, die waren alle fucking. Paläontologen auf der ganzen Welt graben nochmal aus, hier muss doch irgendwas gewesen sein, mit Schweiss auf der Stirn. Was ist denn, hat der nicht irgendjemand so eine Keule als Schwanz? Ja, aber da stellt sich heraus, das war eher so eine Art Rassel. Also der hat eher wie eine Klapperschlange, eher so gerasselt. Ja, still better. Was ist denn mit dem, was ist denn mit dem, der fliegen konnte? Ja, stellt sich raus. Er konnte ein bisschen schneller gehen als der Mensch. Er konnte etwas höher hüpfen als die anderen. Als der Mensch. Etwas niedriger hüpfen als der Mensch. Hüpfosaurus. Ach, es ist eine Art der Zeit. Ja, aber einer hat doch diese der Trissierer-Topf, hat doch diese grossen Hörner. Ja, aber nee, die waren weich. Die waren eher so gummimässig. Die waren eher so kattiges Fruchtgummi weich. Da könnte man, wenn man draufgedrückt hat, haben die so Es war eher eine Hupe, weil der konnte nämlich ganz, konnte nicht gut langsamer werden. Und wenn jemand im Weg stand, konnte der mit den Hörnern rufen. Der konnte auch nicht gut sehen, weil da sind die manchmal ineinander gelaufen, aber dadurch hat es das Geräusch gegeben. Und dann wusste der andere, er muss vorne gehen. Weil es davor, die Produktion hat das halt, weil die so riesen Staus gebildet haben. Ja, standen tatsächlich, Paläontologen finden raus, Dinosaurier standen fast den glaube, man kommt da kaum irgendwie an seinen Zielort, weil überall stehen die im Weg und müssen da ein- und ausparken. Aber das würde ja unserer Stautheorie wahnsinnig zustimmen. Ja, ich glaube auch. Ich glaube auch. Ich glaube auch. Ich hole mir da mal ein gutes Buch, glaube ich. So ein riesengroßes Dinosaurierbuch. Ein richtig dickes Buch. Es war wieder Zeit für eine neue Phase und das wäre eine gute neue Phase. Jetzt kommt wieder die Dino-Phase. Bis du jetzt vielleicht die neue Phase ist, dass du alte Phasen noch mal wiederholst. Die erste Phase, die ich hatte, ja. Was war deine allererste Phase? Ich glaube tatsächlich sowas wie Dinos, nee, mobile. Das war meine erste Phase, da konnte ich nicht genug von bekommen, hatte ich so eine kleine Decke, wo ich mal draufgelegt wurde und über mir war sowas hat sich immer gedreht. Und ich habe das geliebt. Und seitdem, das war meine erste Phase, glaube ich, so Mobile. Und was war das thematisch für ein Mobile? Das war Binnenthematisch. Mobile war das Thema. Achso, das war ein Mobile. Flugsaure, ja. Achso, ich dachte, da hingen dann wieder kleinere Mobiles. Kleinere Mobile. Mobile, tolles Wort. Ganz merkwürdiges Wort. Mobile. Das Mobile. Jeder weiß sofort, was gemeint ist. Das ist so eine Art Fremdwort, was man hier sofort zuordnen kann. Es gibt Fremdwörter und Fremdwörter. Und das weiß wirklich jeder. Ich freue mich jedenfalls sehr auf die nächste wissenschaftliche ... Mittlerweile setzt sich das Schinismus bei mir ein. Es ist auch wirklich so, wenn ich irgendwo eine Schlagzeile lese mit Dino, weiß ich nicht ... Mittlerweile macht es ja fast besser. Also alles, was soll jetzt noch passieren? Was soll jetzt noch passieren? Ja, tatsächlich, wir sind die erste Generation, wo das Legendenbild Dinosaurier bricht. Wir erleben gerade den Fall des Dinosauriers, zukünftige Generationen, weil ich meine, ist es denn jetzt so, die neuen Kinderbücher mit Dinosauriern, werden die denn nach dem aktuellen Standard gedruckt, mit Federn und Pailletten und Blabber und Pferdeschwanz und Sandalen, werden die so gedruckt, ich weiß es gar nicht, oder halten die immer noch an dem alten Bild fest, weil ich glaube wirklich, die neue Generation wird das Interesse an Dinos verlieren und wird übergehend zu anderen Tieren, Tigern oder so. Es gibt ja die fantastische neue App Dino Dino aus dem Hause Bild und Tonfabrik. Vor allem für Kinder, aber auch für Erwachsene zum Durchklicken kann man sehr viel über Dinosaurier lernen. Und da kann man die schon einkleiden mit Federn. Da gibt es quasi so einen Kleiderschrank-Minigame. Aber die Standardvariante ist immer noch nicht mit Federn. Also es scheint auch nicht ganz angekommen zu sein. Da kann man es aber auswechseln zumindest. Aber für Kinder ist es auch offengelassen, die coolere Variante zu nehmen. Wollt ihr über Dinos lernen, wie sie waren? Oder wollt ihr über Dinos lernen, wie sie cool sind?
Es ist so, man hat es noch nicht
ganz akzeptiert. Es fehlt noch die
komplette Akzeptanz. Ja, das ist wie wenn du so eine
Geschichts-App haben würdest, wo du sagen kannst,
oder die Variante Deutschland hat den
Krieg gewonnen. Könnt ihr auch machen, also falls
es euch besser gefällt. Ja, hier kann man den Holocaust
kann man ausblenden und die alle so, what the fuck,
das ist App. Was?
Die haben 200 Panzer mehr jetzt in jetzt in Russland, vielleicht so.
Man nimmt sauer auf die App. Hey App, hey App, was soll das? Sorry. Haben Sie auch keine Lust mehr auf widerspenstige Apps? Dann holen Sie jetzt den App-Vernichter. Ah, gestern ist nämlich plötzlich laube, durch Hamburg, bummele durch Hamburg, schaue mich um, singe und plötzlich fährt an mir vorbei ein Aktenvernichtung, ein riesen Aktenvernichtungs-Service. So ein grosser Lkw. Ich hoffe, er hat mich ausserhin nicht vernichtet. Er hat mich nicht vernichtet, aber wie cool, cool, cool, dass es da irgendwo so Firmen gibt, die zu viele Akten zu vernichten haben oder wichtige Dokumente. Wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich Polizist wäre, ich würde den ganzen Tag hinter dem Aktenvernichtungs-Service hinterherfahren und wenn er dann mal bei der Deutschen Bank vorfährt, würde ich sagen, Momentchen mal, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, halt, ... so Sachen, die wir nicht mehr brauchen, wie zum Beispiel Werbung. Aha, Werbung, zeigen Sie mal. Was ist das hier? Das ist Werbung. Manchmal sehe ich nur so aus, als würde ich lügen. Das ist ja tatsächlich Werbung. Das ist ja Werbung von 2008 bei Penny. Hier braucht niemand mehr. Das soll alles vernichtet werden. Aber die hatten coole Sachen im Angebot. Ah ja, tatsächlich. Hier, 100 Gramm Hackfleisch. 1,9. Ja, das waren auch Preise, ne? Vielleicht ist es zu billig geworden, oder? Finden sie nicht? Ich finde schon, ja. Ey, wie gut das wäre, wenn wir als diese Person den Podcast zu Ende führen würden. Das ich ja genial. Ich meine, die haben reiche Persönlichkeiten. Du meinst, wenn wir die nächsten 20 folgen, nur in diesen Figuren sind Polizistinnen und Mitarbeiter von einem Aktenvernichtungsservice. Vielleicht sind die nämlich ähnlich wie wir, aber das sind andere Menschen, das fände ich schon genial. Na gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen Tag und viel Spaß beim Vernichten.
Vernichten Sie ab und zu auch manchmal Sachen aus Versehen?
Ja, es ist schon mal ein Kind reingefallen.
Oh, das ist natürlich ungünstig.
Das war nicht schön, reden wir nicht gern drüber.
Hatten Sie dann auch so ganz viele kleine Särge?
Kleine Kinder.
Wo dann die, so diese länglichen Särge, so ganz viele längliche Särge, wo die einzelnen, oder nicht? Nee, darüber machen wir auch keine Witze. Das war das Brustproblem. Das war auch von einem guten Kollegen war das die Tochter, die da reingefallen ist. Ja, das ist schrecklich. Die da reingefallen ist in diesen riesen Kessel, muss man sich vorstellen nicht so, wie man so ein Riesen-Kessel, wo drüber auch so weh, also häufig, eigentlich wäre es ein guter Ort für so einen James-Bond-Film. Schauen Sie gerne. Es ist lächerlich, auch weil da oben keine Geländer sind, es ist ein Stahlstreben drüber, perfekt zum Kämpfen. Man fragt sich, warum sind da keine Geländer, warum gehen Wege über diesen riesen Kessel? Ja, und es gibt mehrere Ebenen, die immer höher und höher sich kreiseln. Wer hat das gebaut? So als könnte man runterfallen und dann kurz, bevor man in den Vernichter fällt, sich nochmal irgendwo festhalten. Da gibt es dann wiederum ein paar Streben noch, wo man sich gut dran festhalten kann. Genau, das auf jeden Fall schon. Aber naja, also wenn Sie einen Bond kennen, dann können Sie ja immer Bescheid sagen. Das wäre witzig. Ja, mein Beileid. Mein Beileid. Ich wünsche Ihnen eine fantastische Woche. Oh, danke schön. Ich wünsche Ihnen eine schöne Vernichterwoche. Ich hoffe, es sei eine fantastische Woche. Auch den Leuten da draußen, die uns vielleicht zuhören, wünsche ich eine fantastische Woche. Ja, das wünsche ich euch auch. Macht's gut. Wir sind gespannt, was noch aus der Welt der Dinos passiert. Wir sind gespannt, was du uns zu berichten hast. Vielleicht wirst du doch noch zum Ingenieur. Kurzgifs. Schickt uns eure Kurzgifs. Wir machen das erste Gif Festival. Untertitel Grosse Leidenschaft in 50 Frames. 50 ... Frames. Und wir brauchen auch, denk ringend unbedingt, einen Verlag. Ein Verlagshaus für unser Magazin. Für Random. Also, falls ihr ein kleinesines Independent Verlagshaus gerade aufbauen wollt, ihr habt gerade den Keller fertig und braucht noch ein bisschen Content, schreibt uns an, wir liefern gar nichts.
Macht's gut. Bis dann und wir heben ab.
Macht's gut.
Stefan. Stefan!